da ist plötzlich dieses ungute gefühl es
brennt mehr auf der welt und es brennt
heftiger keller weiß arbeitet für die
organisation global forest lodge dort
analysieren die satellitenbilder von
bränden weltweit sieht sie bisher noch
kein anstieg aber wir sehen trockenere
bedingungen heißes wetter als generellen
trend und das verlängert die brandsaison
und führt darum mehr bränden höhere
temperaturen erhöhen die brandgefahr wie
der wissenschaftler louis féraud vom
weltklimarat pc erklärt wenn die
biosphäre wärmer wird steigt die
verdunstung und wenn die verdunstung
ansteigt trockenen ökosysteme aus und
brennen wo sie das sonst nicht tun
würden
es gibt so viele gebiete in denen es
brennt und nicht darüber berichtet wird
die provinz alberta im westen von kanada
hat ihre schlimmste brandsaison im jahr
2019 erlebt massive brände es war mehr
feuer als sie jemals zuvor erlebt haben
auch in deutschland sieht man folgen
rund 2300 49 hektar wald haben im jahr
2018 gebrannt das ist die zweitgrößte
betroffene waldfläche seit beginn der
waldbrand statistik zum vergleich 1998
waren es nur 397 hektar
landwirtschaftsflächen und feuchtgebiete
wie moore standen in der vergangenheit
auch in brand im europäischen ausland
richten brenne ebenfalls katastrophale
schäden an 2018 brannte der athener
vorort martin über 100 menschen starben
das ist aber natürlich immer eine
kombination von faktoren also meistens
werden zum beispiel in europa feuer
nicht ausgelöst durch klimatische
gegebenheiten oder eben durch
blitzschlag oder so sondern eben
eigentlich durch brandstiftung oder
unachtsamkeit aber die klimatischen
bedingungen die dahinter stehen die
bewirken dann sozusagen ob es ein
katastrophales feuer wird oder nicht
doch nicht nur die bedrohung durch
zunehmende feuer verursacht sorge ein
landschaft und wälder brennen werden
unmengen von co2 ausgestoßen und das hat
einfluss auf den klimawandel in some
cases sie habe ich in indonesien gab es
2015 sehr intensive brände über einen
zeitraum von drei wochen wurden durch
die brände mehr emissionen ausgestoßen
als die gesamte wirtschaft in
deutschland pro jahr produziert die
brände bevor er also den klimawandel und
der wiederum vergrößert risiko und
ausmaß solcher brandkatastrophen ein
teufelskreis